schön dass heute geht es um das böse ist
es überhaupt sinnvoll dass über böses
treten und davon sprechen
der begriff des bösen ist ein bisschen
verrucht nächte die aus vergangenen
zeiten stammen böse kommt in filmen vor
star wars darth vader bösen mächte
gehört das böse nicht eins im film wie
im märchen oder ein action figuren
wichtige zuckerberg dann gut und böse
genau das ist die frage sollten wir das
böse lich er in dem film verband im
märchen geschichten
ich glaube dass wir im begriff des bösen
zu verwenden können auf die kritische
art reflektierte hat dass wir ihn auf
unsere welt anwenden können also auf
verhältnisse in dieser welt auf
inzwischen menschen diese aktionen
natürlich fragen wie sollen wir uns dann
das böse vorstellen sicherlich nicht
mehr als dass dem wunsch sondern mein
vorschlag bezogen auf einstellungen
gegenüber der welt einstellung gegenüber
anderen personen und bösen diesem
kritischen finden wäre demnach eine
handlung die die eigenen treffen
jemand hat prinzipiell über die
interessen an anderen personen oder über
die interessen der menschheit und der
welt insgesamt stellt das wäre so einen
falschen etwas sagen wird das ist
unmoralisch oder vielleicht auch wenn es
dann im endeffekt auch noch viel leid
für das macht umso mehr
nun hast du ja würde zu sagen das was du
gerade gesagt das war auch eigentlich
eine antwort darauf was böse bedeutet ja
also es muss etwas sein was der freiheit
des menschen müsse angegangen werden
immer aus freiheit des menschen und
nicht dass hier aus defekten oder
einschreiben
dann würden wir sagen das ist ein mangel
an unvermögen menschen wenn wir sagen
dass sie die nase des staates lösen
dann setzen wir voraus dass der
menschliche freiheit heraus getan hat
wer hätte sie auch anders können
genau da gibt es ganz verschiedene
meinungen über das böse
die klassische theorie des bösen die
privatisierung des bösen die war lange
zeit im mittelalter vorherrschend
artikulation zügiges böse gesagt das
böse ist ein mangel an guten also das
was nicht gut ist böse genau wir haben
also eine graduelle kato linie sozusagen
und können sagen
1 pol denn das gute und je weiter gehen
und in richtung des anderen pools
bewegen umso weniger gut ist das ganze
lässt das böse sein an dem gratis guten
die weniger gut etwas situation jedes
böse dieser theorie das böse auch nicht
zum eigenen status
es ist immer nur im vergleich zum guten
es wird an guten gemessen auf seine
existenz
das blöde situation zu tendenziell
weniger sein als das gute das aber dass
genau wenn wir jetzt was gute als ideal
haben das dann wären das gute ja gar
nicht vorhanden sondern alles wäre würde
daher nicht geben
genau das ist natürlich auch die frage
strebt wirklich alles aufs gute hin ja
wenn wir uns die welt anschauen
die verträge zunächst 100 könnte man der
meinung sein leben nicht alles strebt
zum moralischen wir haben leider immer
wieder viele menschen viel böses begehen
ihren individualinteressen über die
anderen interessen setzen und das legt
nahe dass wir einen anderen begriff des
nicht ein schiff der prävention betrieb
der perfektion eine perversion
demnach ist das müssen selbst etwas
zeigen stehen weniger fein und das gute
innere aktivität diese individuelle
freiheit verdankt diese kampagne
durchaus nach dieser theorie willentlich
begangen werden
und das liegt zb mal wenn wir uns
überfälle anschauen ganz so langwierig
geplanten banküberfällen verbrechen im
minutiös geplanten der perfekte mord
wird niemand sagen
die unterhaltung aktivität genau
deswegen glaube ich dass eine person
angemessen ist dem phänomen als
einverständnis als nation okay gibt es
neue form des bösen wahlrecht klassische
formen geredet wo man auch im alltag
eigentlich gut ganz gut sein könnte und
dass es böse und das gut und damit
einverstanden wir aber irgendwie ab dem
zwanzigsten jahrhundert vielleicht schon
früher haben sich was geändert dem
holocaust zum beispiel oder auch so was
wie moderne sklaverei
[Musik]
wichtig also die moderne hat die
menschheit neue form des bösen
vorgebracht und eine bekannte denkerin
dieser theorie entwickelt hat ist hannah
arendt begriff aber den topos und das
wort eine banalität des bösen geprägt
die philosophie kennt den schulen wo
halt jemanden der verzweifelt ist dessen
verzweiflung die mit einem gewissen adel
und gibt will nicht leugnen dass dieser
typ des übeltäters existiert dass die
größten über die wir kennen nicht ihm
zuschreibt sind das ist wieder in die
augen sehen muss dass er nicht vergessen
kann jetzt kommen die größte übel setzen
jene die sich nicht erinnern aber sie
auf das getan niemals gedanken
verschwendet haben und ohne erinnerung
kann nicht viel zurück denken an
vergangenen angelegenheiten bedeutet für
menschliche wesen sich in der dimension
der tiere zu begeben wurzeln zu schlagen
und so die selbst zu stabilisieren so
dass man nicht bei allen sind den
zeitgeist geschichte oder einfach der
versuchung dem weggeschwemmt wird das
größte lösen sagt karan ist nichts
radikales hat keine wurzeln
weil er keine wurzeln hat hat es keine
grenzen kannst du uns unvorstellbar
extrem entwickeln
über die ganze welt ausbreiten banalität
des bösen meint machen abend nicht das
böse was im nationalsozialismus begangen
wurde
banal sei das wäre ein falsches
verständnis ja ziemlich sondern die
meinen damit dass das böse im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert eben nicht mehr
dämonisch wir miteinander einzelpersonen
zum beispiel andere person sagte zu
ihnen
das fertige nazi verbrechen war gerade
dass sie will endlich auf alle
persönlichen eigenschaften verzichteten
als ob da niemand mehr übrig bliebe den
wieder bestraft oder den vergeben werden
könnte immer wieder beteuerten sie
niemals das aus
initiative getan zu haben sie habe keine
wie auch immer geartete bösen absichten
und immer nur viel erfolg
das banale böse wäre eine form des bösen
wo sich die täter selbst nur als kleine
rädchen im getriebe eines größeren
systems verstehen und damit jegliche
schuld abladen können auf das system
heute natürlich nicht als entschuldigung
sondern diese form des besteht gerade
darin sich selbst allzugut zu entziehen
deswegen denken natürlich zweideutig
denken kann bedeuten dass man etwas
biosystems etwas bis das kann aber auch
bedeuten bedeuten kann
aber das denken selbst kann böse sein
auch wieder medium das denken sind keine
harmlose freizeitbeschäftigung ist nicht
gestolpert
die sin verhandeln dass eine bestimmte
denkungsart folgt jederzeit
verantwortlich was heißt dass wir es
auch anders machen können soll
handlungen sind böse oder will
maxime wie wir bei kant geschrieben
haben in einer vorherigen sendungen auch
das denken selbst die denkungsart die
hat hier auch einen neuen begriff
akademische kein versehen auch keine
banalität des bösen auch kein mangel an
vorstellungskraft soll ein böses das
wissen und denken sie zum integriert und
der besuch lu und konsequent vorgeht
dass dahinter nicht zu verbergen ist das
sie müssen auch hier in universität
aufpassen wie wir bei umicore
schlusswort ich hätte nur jetzt auch
eine andere frage die ich anhängen
wollen würde
und zwar gibt es ja personen die
behaupten es gibt nichts böses und dass
auch menschen töten nicht böse ist
was bedeutet das der wäre gleichen fall
von relativismus als gibt zwei gründe
warum zu seiner auffassung kommt und
eine wäre zum moralischen relativismus
es gibt gar nicht gut an diese erfindung
die position friedrich nietzsches
ebenfalls von gut und böse sind die
krise die aus einer sklaven moral
entspringen um den stärkeren ein
schlechtes gewissen zu machen
darauf würde ich dann antworten ein
solcher vorwurf dass die sklaven
schwachen dem starken gewissen nicht
gerade den sklaven aus einer moralischen
sichtweise dass genau das gleiche los
die sklaven gemacht haben dass man das
als wäre da ja gerade billig nietzsches
rückfragen verbindet er nicht doch
irgendwie wieder voraussetzen und eine
andere möglichkeit das böse zu
bestreiten stelle darin sagen wir sind
alle nicht frei
wir haben keine freiheit uns zumuten zu
müssen
wegen solchen defekten sprechen und da
bieten antworten natürlich ein sehr
radikales menschenbild unsere
fatalistischen spielt ja dass wir nicht
ohne weiteres zu annehmen sollten damit
sich unsere gesamte einstellung zur welt
ändern nicht trennungsgrund kurve gerade
so ein verhalten alles vorherbestimmt
werde
und um zu verstehen selbst kein begriff
des bösen gäbe wäre menschen töten ja
immer noch nicht in ordnung in ordnung
das ist halt das was ich denke also
genauer unabhängigkeit realität von
bösen haben genau weil ost
lösungsversuch das kann dieses böse
leben nicht vorhandensein des bösen als
rechtfertigung dafür genommen wird
schlimme dinge für den gemüsemärkten
selbst wenn die christen haben sollten
wir nicht hätten sollten eher schlicht
nicht alles tun was uns beliebt
sie sollten versuchen entwickelt des
bösen zu entwickeln und bedient wenn wir
eine ahnung haben das ist damit nicht
mit rechten dingen zu zugelassenen
gesagt haben so eine art pflicht und ein
begriff des guten zu machen was nicht
teil platz des bösen unkritisch
verwenden folgen wir können natürlich
den begriff des bösen erzogen geben dass
wir in gemüse verwenden im sinne dieses
bösen denken wie andere diskriminieren
und abstimmen
das wäre selbst wiederum ein böser
begriff des bösen